en ce moment il y a un journaliste euh
qui fait qui qui m'appelle tout le monde
s'ils font des enquêtes sur moi de
partout pour savoir si je prends de la
drogue alors je peux lui dire c'est pas
la peine de chercher je prends pas
dedans je suis agité de nature
tu vois ma mère tu as compris tu mets
une cigarette moi je te dis voilà on a
jamais on fume pas on boit pas on se
drogue pas mais par contre on vous
emmerde voilà
donc il continue sa petite enquête là
c'est petit enquêtes là donc voilà il
est persuadé parce que je lui dis un
truc il paraît et c'est Castaldi qui me
disait ça il me disait qu'on peut pas
faire une émission comme ça tous les
jours si on prend la possible pourquoi
ça fait quoi là d'abord c'est pas bon
pour la santé déjà et si on a pris toi
ouais ça va être arrivé si si si
tu as pris moi j'ai commencé tout petit
euh quand j'étais dans le biberon quand
j'étais quand j'ai passé quand j'ai
passé mon bac j'avais entendu parler
d'un produit qui s'appelait l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur c'est un
produit qui était en fait c'est des
amphétamines et on m'avait dit si tu
prends ça tu vas apprendre beaucoup plus
vite et donc j'ai été déjà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec ça avec ce produit j'ai fait mes
études avec ce produit et c'est une
connerie d'ailleurs et pour répondre à
votre question après quand tu faisais
des émissions
j'en connais qui est l'antenne où il
sortait pour aller faire le besoin
par exemple ceux qui vont aux toilettes
avec le micro qui est encore branché il
y a quelques ustensiles ah ouais non
arrête
ils sont là ou pas
dans la merde
ce résumé de dire le showbiz alors je
vous rassure c'est pas que le showbiz
c'est il y a plein plein de domaines
dans lequel c'est le travail tu
regrettes aujourd'hui ou pas alors moi
je regarde un il faut pas le faire moi
j'ai eu la chance de d'être épargné par
au travers de cette drogue voilà ça fait
quoi ça fait quoi en fait alors moi la
différence c'est que comme je suis déjà
j'étais comme vous un peu de nature moi
ça me calme hein c'est pas non plus
hyper agité un frère on dit pas quand il
y a une soirée il y a Benjamin Castaldi
à l'époque parce que vous sentez pas
avec moi mais tiens pas en place hein
voilà donc effectivement c'est pas
possible de faire 3 heures de direct en
prenant cette drogue parce que il faut
sortir toutes les toutes les 20 minutes
donc ce qui est pas votre cas et surtout
on a on a laissé la bouche pâteuse un
peu particulier
donc c'est comme vous tu as quand même
beaucoup de symptômes
la vérité moi je suis pas du tout
là-dedans je l'ai il le savent ici bien
sûr je suis pas du tout là-dedans je
suis très heureux comme ça je vous dis
ça c'est vraiment ça c'est un engrenage
à chaque fois que j'ai vu des mecs
et puis regardez non mais c'est voilà et
puis c'est de la merde on peut s'amuser
sans ça moi vous m'appelez je fais une
darka on rigole ensemble c'est mieux que
de voilà bon ça vous coûtera moins cher
je peux faire des barrières des mariages
des barres médecins mais du coup quel
est votre secret pour être en forme
comme ça
dis-moi quand tu fais 4 heures de sport
par jour
tu as des cours renaisses comme des
asperges
[Musique]
mais oui oui oui et ça rend complètement
euphorique et là comme vous êtes
regardez énormément par les jeunes si
vous me permettez j'aurais passé un
message parce qu'il y a des policiers
qui m'ont contacté pour redire avant les
fêtes à tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent il y a un produit qui circule
en ce moment que le 3 MMC est vendu dans
les soirées ça a une odeur de réglisse
ou en poudre blanche c'est extrêmement
trompeur c'est festif on vous propose ça
vous vous sentez bien et ça a des effets
secondaires dévastateur vous pouvez
mourir donc si les jeunes en soirée à
cette période
la merde c'est que vous mettez le doigt
dans un dans un truc voilà c'est un
nombre d'attention à vous et on peut
s'amuser les jeunes et raconter notre
histoire moi je peux vous dire aussi que
quand j'étais jeune bah je fumais des
joints comme malheureusement beaucoup de
jeunes quand on fume des joints on peut
être ail et ben moi je suis resté hype
pendant un an tout simplement donc
prenez pas ça parce qu'en fait ça peut
vous [ __ ] la vie à jamais
et moi moi quand j'étais mannequin il y
avait beaucoup qui prenaient de la
cocaïne
et j'ai vu que des drames autour de moi
des tentatives de suicide des
dépressions des filles complètement
après désocialisé qui perdaient leur ami
qui perdaient leur famille je n'ai vu
que des drames absolus voilà Benaim toi
qui a plongé dans le milieu
merci
est-ce que tu as déjà vu un animateur ou
un truc comme ça avec qui tu travailles
dit la vérité les mecs en télé dis la
vérité oui bien sûr je les ai pas vu on
savait on savait ce qu'ils allaient
faire quand ils allaient dans la pièce
d'à côté mais je ne les ai pas vus
évidemment et toutes les équipes
savaient et
la difficulté que vous avez beau même si
vous êtes très proche de la personne si
vous lui dites il y a que la personne
elle-même qui peut se prendre en main
est décider elle-même d'arrêter il peut
y avoir la terre entière des gens même
très proches qui le lui disent elle
n'entendra pas et évidemment au bout
d'un moment c'est la personne qui décide
elle toute seule d'arrêter ou pas et
heureusement elle est en tout cas les
personnes auxquelles je pense on va
arrêter donc voilà c'est encore là mais
bon
non mais toi dans le milieu tu as vu toi
depuis que toi tu viens pas de notre
milieu alors moi j'étais surpris parce
que je me suis j'ai pensé que en venant
ici j'en verrai une fois au moins je me
suis je vais au moins péter quelqu'un au
moins un vois pas au moins griller un
mec ou dans les toilettes ou avant
l'émission et depuis le temps que je
suis là rien que dalle rien c'est ça que
j'allais dire au final on s'attend à
avoir des trucs boudins quand on arrive
à la télé parce que moi non plus je suis
pas à la télé j'ai jamais vu la drogue
alors peut-être qu'on a une chaîne à
part j'en sais rien parce que c'est
dirigé par vous et vous êtes
non mais en simple contributeur
et j'essaie de joindre les deux bouts
c'est pas facile
avant dans la télé mais en tout cas moi
j'ai jamais vu de drogue depuis que je
suis arrivée sur cette chaîne et quand
tu vas en soirée et qu'on voit les gens
qui se droguent bah c'est con à dire
mais la plupart du temps c'est des je
sais pas des traders des banquiers des
gens qui ont les sous déjà pour se
fournir cette cam qui est hyper cher
mais généralement moi c'est pas les gens
de la télé que je fasse droguer c'est
c'est des gens qui ont beaucoup de
pression dans leur vie et qui se perdent
dans ce truc de merde on a vraiment pas
de pression et nous on a pas autant de
vous retrouver la seule pression que
j'ai c'est quand je perds en finale d'un
tournoi non je vais dire c'est même plus
vrai ce qu'il y a des gens qui nous
regardent et qui habitent certainement
dans les villages dans les campagnes
dans les petites villes et maintenant ça
s'est répandu parce que justement
d'après ce qu'on voit dans les
reportages les prix ont énormément
baissé et donc malheureusement c'est la
portée de tous aujourd'hui et ça fait
des ravages aussi à la campagne dans les
petites villes c'est pas que les dans
les grandes capitales et métropoles
par contre j'ai vu beaucoup de
producteurs en prendre il y a une époque
il y a une dizaine d'années même dans
les salles de montage ça tapait des
rails de coupe donc bien sûr que si bien
sûr il bien sûr évidemment et en fait il
y a une espèce de légende qui dit que
les gens de la télé en prennent pour
tenir mais en fait c'est pas du tout
vrai ils prennent juste ça pour faire la
fête et pour se donner un genre et faire
donner le sentiment d'appartenir à une
pseudo mais voilà et en réalité c'est
des gens qui qui sont extrêmement seuls
qui sont extrêmement déprimés dépressifs
qui ont des sauts d'humeur
insupportables donc c'est de la merde il
faut surtout pas prendre mais il y en a
il y en a à la télé mais plus les gens
en production quarantaine je tiens j'ai
vu un chien journaliste moi un abruti là
de Charlie Hebdo là qui a dit ouais qui
a dit qui a dit aussi ouais Cyril doit
prendre de la faire une vanne fort tout
ça voilà je cherche euh
voilà sympathiquement pour discuter vous
savez je suis j'adore j'adore discuter
apparemment c'est un anglais je sais pas
on va dire
faut toujours la merde on a un Moktar on
le sait depuis le stade de France il
faut toujours la merde bon en tout cas
je vous le dis donc il y a des il y a
des journées qui vont vous appeler pour
savoir s'il y a de la drogue dans TPMP
sachez-le voilà bon bah écoutez ils
peuvent enquêter ils peuvent venir ici
s'ils veulent par contre je les
accueillerai moi-même